I'm running the Olympia I gotta sell VIP
seats that last Olympia I saw I had 660
VIP seats sold going in every seat at
$650 you can multiply it out
times how much particular 650 650 at 600
tickets 660 tickets but it gets even
better in that last Olympia in 2003 to
Iran I go back to my room after the
judging now there was a lot of things
going on in that show and my room is the
sweetest packed I would have Dinah
Anderson a form of female bodybuilder
and her husband in the other room
because she was a legal secretary and
Carlo was there from Italy because he
was the computer guy and other people
and I can't even get in my room I said
what's going on here they go win it's
sold out and they want tickets and guys
are going to Wayne please please please
I said let me see what I can do the
other guy that was there was Giorgio to
kalos the star of ancient aliens George
Jones like my other son I met Herman in
Europe when he was 16 he want to be a
promoter he did promote for me for five
years and he was up there too he'd
always helped me a children so I call
the box office
I go Kim I'm looking at the schematic
can we fit in to all the rules of
folding chairs in the back on both sides
of the center section she goes Wayne for
you I'll because I picked the girls from
the box office out every time I go on a
production meeting I go on a Friday
because they'd never go back to work I'd
take them to the Mexican restaurant we'd
all get drunk they call the fire marshal
they call the head of Mandalay Bay and
everything they go Wayne they'll do it
till it's two rows of 16 on each side
that's 64 seats but the fire marshal
wants us two sons to be able to go
backstage and some of the executives
want their son I said have all the sons
come they'll they hang with me backstage
the whole show they go done so I go to
the people in my room I said they're
printing up tickets now I said George
you go down to Kim and get the tickets
you're gonna get the finals you'll get
the banquet and you get the seminar
tomorrow I'm not gonna charge you 650 I
got a charge of 600 and it's got to be
cash you've got time when Giorgio comes
back
you're getting a line you give me the
cash sold in no time they wanted to see
a show they know it was gonna be a good
show they know it's gonna be
entertaining we ran that show we had a
script on the night show both that in
Night of Champions minute by minute we
knew exactly everything we'd collect the
music on the Wednesday night at the
meeting
we'd have we knew the order of the
competitors so let's say a guy out of
music
eight nine minutes hey you got eight
nine minutes on oh I'm only gonna do the
first two minutes and 45 seconds okay we
did it
put it on there put it on a mini disc
cleaned it so the acoustic Li was
perfect
on a mini disc in that order we just
pushed the number song number one
Porsche it comes right out so if he
wanted it as he enters a stage or in
position we had it we had all their
everybody's on headphones the sound guy
the lighting guys Charlie calling a show
me backstage all the backstage people it
was long like a regular Broadway play
the stagehands would say to us we can't
believe you do so much here for a one
night show what kind of money you're
making at this time at the Olympia oh I
can tell you the money on the Olympia
and you know I'd fight with the weeders
on the Olympic was they always wanted
more and more that last Olympia our
expenses were 1.65 million and we gave
away four hundred thousand four hundred
ten thousand and the cadillac escalade
and we took in about two point two six
two point almost two point three okay so
we made close to 600 thousand okay on
the show but when you look at it
percentage-wise we're making like twenty
seven percent of the gross a normal
business if you do ten percent you're
doing great normal is eight percent you
were doing twenty seven twenty eight
percent is that what the athletes were
upset about the fact that they could got
a more cash out of it or no I was
raising the prize money every year you
know you don't know what the attendance
is going to be I raised it every year
and then every year they're adding in
you got to remember that was just the
men
I had women's bodybuilding yeah I had
fitness bodybuilding and by 2003 I had
figure
[Music]